السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره استشهد شاب
الفلسطينيون برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مخيم اليد الدهيشه للاجئين
في مدينه بيت لحم وقالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ان الشعب عمر مناع استشهد
نتيجه اصابته بالرصاص الحي في الصدر خلال
مواجهات وقعت لدى اقتحام القوات الاحتلال
المخيم فجر اليوم
وفي جنين سحبت قوات الاحتلال من اطراف
المخيم بعد اعتقال الاسير المحرر يحيى
السعدي نجل القيادي البارز في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي بسام السعدي من منزله غربي
شهود عيان ان اشتباكات مسلحه دارت بين
فلسطينيين وقوه الاحتلال خلال محاولتها
اقتحام المخيم دون وقوع اصابات
قال المستشار الالماني انه سيكون من الخطا
الفاتحه التوقف تماما عن الحديث مع الرئيس
الروسي بلعدي ميرفتن على الرغم من كل
الاختلافات معه
الى ذلك قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون انه يعتزم التحدث مع الرئيس
الاوكراني
فولوديميرنسكي قبل اجراء محادثات هاتفيه
مع بوتين وكان ماكرون قد ذكر في وقت سابق
انه سيناقش وضع طاقه النوويه في اوكرانيا
مع الرئيس الروسي
عن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الى ان الرئيس الروسي يرغب في اجراء
المحادثاتهم ذاتي مخزن بشان التوسل لتسويه
في الحرب
وصلت معدات عسكريه امريكيه الى ميناء
دينيا في بولندا في طريق برنامج لاعاده
انتشار المعدات والقوات التابعه للنيترو
وتشكل جزءا من نحوي
2400 مركبه وصلت الى بولندا واليونان من
فرقه المشاه الاولى التابعه للجيش
الامريكي
تبدا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم العمله
بسقف الاسعار الذي حددته دول مجموعه هي
السبعه واستراليا لشراء النفط الروسيه
دولارات للبرميل كحد اقصى وكان الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقد وافق على تحديد السقف في
قرار يرى الاتحاد انه سيحرم موسكو من مصدر
كبير من مصادر دخلها لاستخدامه في حربها
على اوكرانيا
لوح نايب ورئيس الوزراء الروسيه اليكساندر
نوفاك بخفض بلاده انتاجها من النفط
ومشتقاته قائلا من بلده لن تبيع النفقه
والمواد البتروليه الا للدول التي تعمل
وفق شروط السوق حتى لو تسبب ذلك في خفض
الانتاج وهو ما اثار مخاوفه من احتمال
اضطراب اسواق الطاقه
وقد اتفقته بلس على تمديد العمل بسياستها
الحاليه في انتاج النفط ويشمل ذلك لايقاع
على المسار الذي اقر في اكتوبر القاضي
بخفض الانتاج بمليونير من يوميا حتى نهايه
عام 2000 و 2320
قال المدعي العام الايراني محمد جعفر
منتظرين الجهات التي انشات شرطه الاخلاق
اتخذت قرارا بوقف عمل المنظومه في هذه
المرحله واكد ان البرلمان والمجلس الاعلى
للثوره يبحثان مساله الحجاب
وسيعلينان النتائج خلال اسبوعين
في اثناء التامه وزير الخارجيه الايراني
حسين امير عبد الله يعني الولايات المتحده
ودول اخرى بتشجيع الاحداث داخل بلاده بهدف
الضغط عليها لتقديم تنازلات
انتهى الموجز السلام عليكم